take big risks early not later
why
so I've debated this with friends but
the bottom line is is that
for most people future you
has other people and other obligations
and you cannot recover
as quickly
right like I use the example like Opana
was like smoking weed and crack and then
you know he's President right like it's
hard to be smoking for weed and crack
now and then you know later in life and
be present you can recover from so many
things you can [__] around for four
years and then go to med school and
become a brain surgeon right and you
don't have kids other obligations
a path that you've dug for yourself
that's harder to get out you can
reorient yourself and have met your your
time billionaire you have a billion
seconds right so you have a lot of time
to recover reorient yourself and
still have a very very fulfilling life
the consequences of taking what seems
like big risks are not as great because
of your ability to heal and recover it's
the same thing physically
right
if I tear something [__] it's gonna take
a long time to get a 17 year old tears
something like
my daughter had uh she got airlifted um
out of out of Aspen to Denver Children's
right she got this infection and I don't
know she was traveling and kids have
porous bones so it went to the back of
her eye and it was going to go in her
brain they're like your daughter has to
go now so they took her out of a small
hospital and Aspen whatever she had two
surgeries I was bulging out her resting
heart rate was 150 560. I'm panicking
right so they do the surgery she you
know she's out of it I thought this is
less time to see my daughter a week
later she's like can I go to camp
can I go swimming look what the [__]
you alien what are you made of exactly
you know Rubber and Magic you know and
like when you when you have two kids
like I I you know your first kid you're
like oh my God they have a fever you're
running to the hospital you're yelling
and screaming at each other they
dropping and fall you're like flipping
out over everything right by the second
kid you like uh rolling around here
they'll be fine it'll be fine right let
me be fine and so but if I felt like
that or I get sick like that or if my
resting heart rate is 155. you know
they're like calling the priest
calling the priest right and so
this is like your time the the
asymmetric aspect sorry about that that
is my six o'clock alarm one of the
Technologies I use that uh reminds me
and prompts me to connect with my wife
so you would usually ring her text her
what would be able to know each other's
presents we'll usually maybe do an hour
we would try and get an hour in we'll
chat with each other we'll drop
everything and we'll connect or if we're
busy whatever's just like hey baby I
love you like I love you too what's
going on how was your day right it's
cool so one of the Technologies you use
is you know when llms and everything
it's going to be greater it's going to
be great like you're gonna have they're
gonna ingest that would zero they're
gonna adjust a thousand questions from
me
um some of the other tools that other
people have built on top of it there's
going to be llm and you're just gonna be
able to ask it questions and it's going
to be able to answer like should I do
this or whatever well according to the
philosophy according to the spreadsheet
so-and-so build according to your
finances so I can't wait till that
happens because that's originally what I
wanted I didn't want a [__] book uh
wanted to Auto die with xero I wanted
this app for me to tell me what to do
like you don't have a chef and they tell
me what to eat I want to think like Bill
go on a boat trip or after the boat trip
you're going to Vietnam camp this trail
hike here stay in this Hut I know you
don't like staying in Huts but you're
gonna love it you know is that you're a
hexaco personality profile exactly
exactly and then just keep just ideating
and giving me the adventure so then when
I hit the grave I have all these scars
and I'm like I use this [__] thing up
I had a great ride but uh
going back to this take risk early right
like I'm I
I Can't Jump the Wake the wakeboard
awake right now I can't I can't do I
can't do these things and so the the
asymmetric asymmetry of the wrists
you know starts to disappear
right but early means now like what risk
you can take now means early and
sometimes everybody always thinks
Financial right always thinks Financial
I'm like tell the [__] girl you love
her first
bear your heart
take the ride
it's probably gonna get broken but
that's great you'll learn from it you
know
sometimes it means that
sometimes it means just just make the
move what would you say to the people
who feel like they want to maximize
their life but they are risk-averse in
life decisions and job changes and
breaking up with partners that are not
right for them in finances what would
you say to them all right I'm going to
say something a little bit different the
first thing I would say is [__] the
haters because a lot of the times you
don't do something it's because you're
afraid of being judged by other people a
lot of people can stand the Financial
Risk or even like the emotional risk or
whatever they cannot stand the Whispers
And Judgment of people thinking I told
you so
a lot of people I I tell people this
whole time people like success but they
love a failure
and failure validates their own
cowardice right so when you go out and
you try the business and think and you
fail they're like
I don't look like an idiot for not
trying myself see Jim Jim over here he
failed
so I don't have to try that's why I can
live this miserable job that I'm afraid
to quit or whatever if you go quit you
go [__] succeed
[__]
they're they're exposed their own
cowardice is exposed right
but I say just go live the adventure
like it's not we I think we focus too
much I want to podcast and I I you know
I respect all these podcasters out there
getting ideas out to people summarizing
them taking a long-ass blathering boring
guy like me making it interesting and
putting it out there for people but I
want the guys who tried and failed
I want the guys like [__] really and
then what happened and oh my God those
are those are heroes man
you know we we always catch the the the
we always have we always talk to the
salmon who's Upstream spawning
you know but we need some of the salmon
that like [__] I went the wrong way and
I got eaten by a bear yeah I mean
obviously you can't talk but like you
know like this is what happened when I
tried I tried this right you know
because there's just learnings in that
and there and there's there's a good
ride and there's a lot of people who
have failed like I wouldn't do anything
different right maybe I tweaked the
thing or this didn't happen to the bad
thing or I would have been nicer to the
employee and he wouldn't quit or
whatever but like there's learnings in
that and that's right the selection
effect of of the people who have the
most notoriety are the ones that
least familiar with failure or at least
at least familiar with big failure
catastrophic failure which creates a
world of people who are successes and
only successes talking and giving advice
which probably creates a culture
Downstream from that of people who are
hyper sensitized to failure I've been
busted twice after making it you know
what I mean I've I've I've gotten
divorced worse failure in my life right
like I've I've had some huge failures
you know and some huge tries and so
I'm here on your podcast people are
actually going to listen to me talk my
[__] and you know to the person out
there
you know who's out there who's on the
edge or you know if they really think
about it like
it's it's a lot of it's your fear of
being judged
and you judging yourself
just do your best that's all you can do
get out there take Life by the balls
like don't live if you like there is
some Romanticism and I don't want to
take away from it from the cookie cutter
Simple Life
there are some people out there who
truly enjoy it like the tail end of my
life I would love to be a farmer
a not knee of growing things in the
intricacy right but right now
oh
um I want scars man I want the right I
do not want the cookie cutter life I
don't want to waste this ride and so for
the person out there who's like
cookie cuttering it but like really
yearns to like
strike out try anything move to the new
City chase the girl say I love you first
you know what I mean get in shape run
the marathon whatever it is right like
don't waste your [__] life dude don't
do it don't let the [__] Judgment of
the haters make you waste your [__]
life what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace